hey guys Ryan right over here and Brady
friends over here Alex Luther King of
epic fan made trailers King because he
is the only one with the title epic van
may trailers has made Marvel Ultimate
Alliance I want to check out this
trailer because everyone is saying this
is the next one from mr. Luthor that we
should check out
yeah yeah
join me
imagine what we could accomplish
together
but me to be
ah
the
just don't know
is a Virgo
ah
nothing but our wit and our will they
work so stand and try to
we can tear apart a wall will wrench
your cities will not be set the streets
will not descend you will not miss
me
we must make amenity hashman are
where's the frickin guardians of the
galaxy when we stand together office
budget jackass in a circle
you just go sit there
Wow
yeah oh my god this little picture of me
right now you got issues
oh my god damn dearly like the coolest
ever
you know I'm always like paying
attention to the edit so much I'm like
what if I just got lost in this trailer
for a second you know like and just try
to accept it for like what it is is if
it's something real and when you do that
it looks [ __ ] amazing like like it
doesn't look it looks like yes this is
it they've done it they've created the
Ultimate Marvel Universe if Fox could do
what Sony did we can have the Ultimate
Marvel Universe they should watch this
trailer they should because we need
Wolfie because one thing I couldn't go
ahead I'm just saying that Hugh
Jackman's announced that he's only a
play Wolverine for the last time for the
Wolverine part 2 or Wolverine 3 I don't
know I think it's three so he's gonna do
that the last time but I'm like you
really want him in the Avengers though
like he's gotta get a chance to be in
the Avengers especially if anyone's
gonna be in the Avengers
it's gotta be Hugh Jackman man it needs
to be it's like you don't just need
Wolverine actually a great way to reboot
Wolverine would be the permanent what we
wouldn't put him in the Avengers indoors
yeah yeah exactly with the new
Wolverines that would make more sense
you know he's one of the Ultimate Marvel
iconic cinema actors you know he's
playing Wolverine for like 15 years now
anybody look the same
he looks looks even better yeah like you
did too but yeah looking at like
Wolverine being a part of this and we
know that spider-man is gonna be a part
of this and a little quick edits the
Spider Man meaning that were great yeah
I love it all I just love the fact that
he uses footage from everything it just
compiles it into something beautiful cuz
sometimes they're not the greatest but
this looked really good I think the
scene looked really good too like the
color grading and all that stuff looked
pretty similar yeah it didn't look like
a bunch of different movie yeah yeah
like it looked like it was one film
that's what made it work so well yeah
for the most part I looked like it was
once one film it didn't look like it was
changing directors and cinematographers
every job the only one that really stood
out was when they brought in guardians
of the galaxy that's true those looked
significantly different but it was still
good there's still great yeah and I'm
glad they brought in guardians of the
galaxy oh yeah I hope they're under
vendors 3 anyway guys thanks for
mentioning that was out thank you Alex
Luthor I love you my buddy I love you if
you needed the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects brandy has a channel
to check that [ __ ] out you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter where
we're like yo mommy this is big hashtag
big penis but I don't say that yeah then
I go on Instagram I'm like here's a
picture I'm up here knows and then I
tweet it and post it to Facebook he does
I don't follow along just because of
that I know you don't follow me not a
lot of people follow me yeah only guys
that I met on Grindr that makes sense
that's unfortunate